[Music]
Hey hey you guys I'm Katie Kraus and I'm
Danny direct though thanks for hanging
out with us here at et yeah Justin
Prentiss is here from 13 reasons why
they've watched season two you are in
for some serious treats because we are
going to ask him everything about it if
not we want to give you a little bit of
a warning spoilers coming your way we're
saving them towards the end of it yes
the correct stick right now send in your
questions if you haven't know we'll make
sure that he gets them but um let's get
right into it
let's do it season two when it picked up
it's two months after season one ends
mm-hmm is that where you thought the
story was going to go we're obviously in
trial we have testimonies from everyone
yeah they kind of told us at the end of
season one if we were to do a second
season and it would probably go
litigious yeah and we get into that side
of things which was exciting and
something we all kind of look forward to
yeah it's it's cool there are a lot of
twists throughout the season that we
absolutely did not see coming
which is fun the biggest twist spoiler
incoming yeah I don't know I think one
of the biggest ones for me that I didn't
see coming was Zak and Hannah because
that one wasn't really foreshadowed all
that much yeah you have the whole guns
storyline my whole case getting let off
easy kind of mirrors the Brock Turner
case so it's reality so there were kind
of hints like sort of along the way but
I feel like that one was just kind of a
blindside out of nowhere it was really
exciting it was really exciting and
that's what's so amazing about this
season is obviously season 1 we kind of
try and map out what led to Hannah's
suicide or this one we really get to see
that the entire cast of characters has
secrets and also has some secret
relationships with Hannah there's a
untold stories there about their
relationships there which is cool yeah
just kind of it builds the whole world
that season ones learn it it connects
the dots a little bit more and goes
deeper especially with your character
yeah I mean what was your reaction when
you first read the scripts did you get
them all at once or was in peace man no
so we film like in two episode block
right
so we kind of get them one at a time
usually and then we'll get one a week
later we'll get the next and then it'll
be like three weeks ish until we get the
next script again yeah so we're always
hanging on the edge of our seat right
you're saying you're reacting in like
immediately texting yeah well I'll call
each other in text and or the first time
we see each other in person we're like
did you read it
what what's going on with oh my gosh
it's crazy when you found out what was
going to happen to your character and
you mentioned the Brock Turner case of
course was that intentional like to
mimic what happened with that I think so
I mean our show is it's fictional and
they're dramatized events but one thing
that it tries to do is sort of like
mirror reality in a sense and kind of
put up a mirror and spotlight the issues
that that our country specifically is
dealing with but really all over the
world and you know Brice's is privileged
comes from a powerful family he's a
straight white male and so it's easier
for him to get off and we see that
happening all the time and it sucks
I know fans are gonna be super pissed
off but you should be pissed off because
that's you know that's the reality right
now is that the point that justice was
not really served yeah you know it's
interesting because I think there were
different forms of justice throughout
the show you know I think like Alecia
her character Jessica kind of she comes
to terms with what happened she's
finally able to look Bryce in the eyes
and and point him out and say you did
this to me and that's a that's such a
huge step for her so in her own way I
think that's kind of her justice and
coming in terms with everything in terms
of actual legal justice right you know
Bryce just kind of gets a slap on the
wrist and a you know don't do it again
you little rascal which is so screwed
but but yeah it's it's realistic yeah
there's no way to put it except that
Bryce is the bad guy you know but I mean
do you feel like you kind of as an actor
take one for the team like there's a
responsibility to play this like person
people know that you did a good job and
I knew what I was signing up for the
get-go and I try not to be a huge
horrible person in my day-to-day life so
as an actor it's kind of rewarding to
stretch a little bit but yeah it's it's
enjoyable I suppose yeah in a weird way
right was there any hesitation knowing
that people might actually hate you they
might have a hard
time you know deciphering between you
and your sister yeah and they're so
invested in these characters which is
great which we love yeah you know when I
first signed on I didn't know how big of
his success the show was gonna be we
didn't know it was gonna be this kind of
cultural phenomenon we were just hoping
it would touch a few people positively
and maybe influenced some people for the
better but we didn't know it was just
gonna erupt the way it did so originally
signing on I I figured I would get a
little bit of hate but I just didn't
know the extent of which I would get the
hate but but it's kind of an honor I
guess sure enough there's a couple of
comments coming in about that yeah Pizza
blurry from u2 wants to know what is the
hardest part of playing Bryce I think as
an actor when you're playing the villain
you kind of you have to justify the
actions which is weird cuz I come from a
family of you know always respect women
my mom and dad both brought an equal
income they both switched off cooking
and cleaning dishes and everything it
was a very equal kind of relationship
which was beautiful to grow up with so
that's kind of been ingrained in me
since I was a child so having to
overcome that and justify Bryce doing
these abhorrent actions I think was one
of the toughest things not that it
justifies what he did just as an actor
you have to find a way to make it make
sense in the characters mind which is
kind of tricky
did your parents watch yes their
response you know that it's really
interesting they've done a great job of
I think separating me from the character
which is really cool because they know
that I'm not Bryce yeah so they kind of
watch it as if I'm not their son in a
sense as if they're just kind of
watching any other actor bring a role to
life and I've been doing this for yeah
good strategy I've been doing this for
kind of a decade now so they understand
sort of how the industry works and easy
probably not no I don't think it was
easy
your grandparents haven't watched it
probably won't probably shouldn't told
us earlier neither have you I know I
haven't watched not even season one I've
seen the first two episodes of season
one because they played them at our
premiere and I was sort of locked into
watching it and wasn't allowed to leave
theatre but were you watching like this
I was just like occasionally I wasn't in
the first two episodes that much so I
was like okay I think I can I can make
it through this
just insecure actor it's fair comments
are coming in
Jada banister says how do you deal with
the hate that you get from playing the
role you get yeah a little bit it's not
usually like oh my gosh I love Brice
he's amazing alright know you which is
good
III take it all kind of as a compliment
and yank it just means I did my job at
least somewhat well I suppose if people
have a hard time differentiating me from
the characters and that's you know I
feel like I did my work yeah well yeah I
also try not to think about it yeah you
mentioned that your parents watched it
but there's a lot of parents out there
who don't feel like they want their kids
to watch this calling for Netflix to
maybe pull down the show do you feel
like that backlash is warranted how do
you respond no I see where they're
coming from but at the same time again
as I said one of the jobs of our show is
to reflect reality so this stuff is
already going on in these high schools
you know these kids are already
experiencing it and their day to day
lives so so having a show where we
address these issues even if you don't
necessarily agree with the way that we
address them the fact that we're
addressing them and raising these
conversations I think it kind of bridges
the gap you know if parents wanted to
watch it with their children again maybe
you don't agree with the way that we
show it but that's that's a conversation
starter and it it bridges that
generational gap and I think it makes
the conversation a little easier to
begin you know for kids opening up to
parents and parents to kids vice versa
and even kids amongst their friends at
the end of the day controversy or not
you know people are talking you know
talk about these issues because that's
the first step in changing and I will
say something I noticed watching this
season compared to last was that the in
the script and in the dialogue I felt
like a lot of the messages were a lot
more pointed you guys a lot more
deliberate would trying to get that
message across yeah so in a lot of ways
I mean I feel like don't you feel like
there's a responsibility there I think
there kind of is you know it's it's one
of those like there's so many issues in
our society right now that can be
changed if we just work towards changing
them so season two is very much alike
okay let's just cut right to the point
yeah this is what's going on be mad
about it be upset about it
angry and let's you know let's change
things totally there's this really big
moment at the end where you see that
montage of women all sharing their
experiences with sexual assaults I'm
curious if you know if that was written
before the me2 and the times that
movement came to be what I'm trying to
think because I remember being on set
when when the whole Weinstein case came
to fruition
yeah and that was one of the big talking
points we were we were mentioning on set
but I don't remember exactly what
episode we were filming because we also
had a lot of reshoots so on any given
day we were filming like episode 11 and
12 while also doing reshoots on episode
6 and episode 1 and 2 and then so it's
everything's kind of jumbled so I don't
remember exactly where we were in
filming it okay but I do remember
showing up to set and all of us going
wow this show is relevant more than ever
I was gonna ask you like how did that
whole scandal and of course our
Weinstein and times up in fact maybe the
vibe of what you guys were doing I think
it just makes it more worthwhile you
know it's just it makes us want to work
even harder than we already were yeah
it's it's an issue it's a problem yeah
yeah Danielle Yates has a question for
you she's asking how did you prepare for
the dialogue scene with your your mother
and the show where he tells her how you
saw the film because it was so intense
yeah I was so excited though when she
slapped you in the face
another small form of justice and pretty
strong is phenomenal I love her as my
right eye
lots of staring in the mirror and just
running the lines with myself just
trying to I guess get it right and then
on the day of you know we rehearsed it a
couple of times and then just sort of in
the moment you just kind of let
everything go and sort of go for it and
yeah hopefully it turned out well cuz it
was really fun to film one of the most
chilling scenes I think in the entire
and it was building a you know his
mother you can tell that she's like I
don't know if I believe him anymore
which is interesting there's a lot going
on there and Bryce's parents have never
really been involved in his life so so
I'm Bryce's mind is like now all of a
sudden you want to have a hand and once
going on and he sort of just drops his
facade and you see the monster kind of
comes through the cracks which is really
interesting and his mother you know
realizing like yeah this right this is
this is we've created a monster
essentially wasn't easy for you to
unplug from this character unwind a
little bit after shooting like once they
yelled cut you know it depends if it's
if it's a lighter scene it's it's a
really kind of easy bounce in and out at
this point but for the really dark
scenes you know Olivette kind of go off
and get in my own sort of headspace and
stay in that and takes a little longer
to pull out of but what we always try
and go out and have a you know play
board games have a game night same line
when you do you break scene or you do
break character do you feel like you
almost need to apologize to the cast
mates I mean with the scenes with
Jessica and with Chloe and sometimes
there are a lot of check-ins you know
through filming like are you still okay
are you doing alright let me know so so
that helps and and they've always every
cast member has been super trustworthy
of me which is immensely helpful but
yeah if anything I think it the
relationship the family that we've kind
of built the cast I think it makes it
easier to jump into the character cuz I
I know that they don't see me that way
so it's it's you know whereas doing a
scene with a stranger afterward you like
by the way I'm not but but now that
we've built up this sort of foundation
of trust it makes it easier to really
just give give it everything be a lot
different if it was day one of season
yeah you mentioned check-ins and I'm
curious because Netflix implemented you
know the PSA at the beginning of the
episodes do they offer anything to you
guys because you are getting so deep and
dark in these characters yeah they've
been immensely helpful with resources
you know we we've all talked to
psychiatrists about everything and and
me specifically sexual assault
preventative experts and and all of that
which is which is awesome in terms of
building the character but also for our
own sort of mental state in season one
we had for the hot tub scene with with
Catherine they had like emotional
support puppies on set which is adorable
and I had seen I asked Catherine
afterwards I was like did you ever go to
the
/ to play with the dog she goes no I
would have just crumbled that was like
me - I stayed as far away as possible
but but it was great for the crew a lot
of the crew was experienced these sort
of traumatic incidents so yeah like they
do everything that they possibly can to
make sure everyone's taken care of so
yeah I mean what would you say is the
biggest impact this role and this show
has had on you as a person um you know I
think how prevalent the issues are
before starting the show you know I knew
they existed and I knew it was going on
but I think in doing all of the research
and and and hearing all the statistics
and really diving into this world you
realize how frequently these issues are
popping up and how many people it
effects I know the cast and I and even
producers writers directors we've all
talked amongst ourselves and in
mentioning this show to our friends and
family members have all had a bunch of
people come forward and be like hey
something like this happened to me and
it's like we never never knew never
realized so I think that was one of the
biggest things is how many people it
really affects and sparking that
conversation is so important and I think
it is and it's it's beautiful that you
know have someone in your life that
you've known forever and and then be
like hey this happened to me you know
like that's a that's a huge step for
them to come forward with something like
that and we get countless letters of
people like hey my friends understand
what I went through now because of the
way you guys portrayed this or it made
it easier for us to talk about this
first of my life which is it's gorgeous
it's a beautiful thing there's a scene
obviously this is another spoiler so I
just want to give you guys the heads up
but the show ends with an almost school
shooting and clay of course stops ed
prevents it from happening but it seems
so reflective of what continuously is
happening and most recently with the
shooting in Houston how do you speak to
that and what do you think that says
about your show again you know we try
and stay as current as possible we have
a bunch of different storylines this
season all kind of touching on all of
these important issues mass shootings
guns are obviously a big one
again just disclaimer our characters are
kids in high school and and it they are
dramatized events and it is a fictional
show and if you're in the position of
clay
go to an adult call nine-one-one there
there are better ways to handle that
situation this is a show and it is
fictional thank you for saying yes yeah
so but you know our our characters are
flawed and I think that's kind of a
beautiful thing too I think especially
like with season one you see Hanna side
of the story but you also see with
season two's is some of you know the
past and what has happened and and
there's there's murky water and there's
murky territory and and and clay doesn't
always make the right decisions and I
think that's more human than anything
and again that's another parallel to
high school you know you don't always
know how to address these issues and our
characters don't always go about it the
right way it's not a it's not a
documentary it's not a PSA though we try
to you know help with these issues as
much as we can but yeah I mean mass
shooting is obviously it's a huge issue
right now and I mean and I'm glad that
in this in this case clays character was
able to placate the the scenario but
that wouldn't necessarily always happen
in real life where do you think the
story goes from there there's already
been talks about a potential season
three right your character says I think
one of the last lines is I'm gonna go
start over I'm transferring right yeah
say to dempsey yeah I guess I'll see you
on the football but it said so Bryce
yeah yeah I I would love to do a third
season they haven't told us Netflix I
said anything
I hope they tell us soon because they
were all we're all very anxious to find
out yeah I don't know I I still think
there is more to explore with the with
the fallout you know it doesn't end
there just because clay stopped this
incident from happening doesn't mean
that Tyler's okay right and body and
mind so yeah I think there's there's
more road to explore and and we as the
cast for for sure I'm excited to explore
it further if they'd let us
and what about Chloe's pregnancy Oh
things that she changed her mind about
testifying because she knew that she was
I think it's certainly a possibility I
think I think that along with looking at
Bryson in the eye and him being there
made it way harder than she thought it
was going to be to single him out
Bryce's is very manipulative
and as we saw in the flashback when they
were kids he wasn't always this monster
of a person so there are bits of
goodness in Bryce and and Bryce kind of
can use that to manipulate people and so
I think I think she's kind of confused
in that moment she doesn't really know
what's up and what's down and she's
remembering the good moments with Bryce
and she's like it could be could be a
good father maybe in a weird way and
it's it's a lot of conflict and I think
that's what kind of silences her in that
moment because it's hard to come forward
and in a weird way Bryce seems like he
could protect and provide right right
I'm like a wealthy family the kid's
gonna have a college fund
you know but at the same time you know
all of this stuff is coming to light and
and Bryce's empire's starting to crumble
and so I'm sure her character is very
very conflicted I think that the topic
of abortion would be something that is
explored then I think it's very much it
could be I think it very much could be
and it would be interesting to see how
they handle it because from my point of
view Bryce comes from a powerful family
and they have a way of making things
disappear so I don't know it'd be very
interesting yeah what does redemption
for Bryce look like is it attainable
yeah a lot of people are asking that
like I think Mike he'll change does he
feel remorse you know he again with the
kids seen there's a human in there
somewhere and I think that was the trick
for me was not painting him as this
disconnected from reality sort of person
you know he's still in touch with the
human side of things at least somewhat
there is a person deep down in there at
this point it's so ingrained in him what
he's done I don't know I I think there
is hope out there for the Bryce is I
don't know that our writers will give
Bryce any redeeming qualities down the
road but it'll be it's time to find out
that's well said yeah I believe that
yeah someone's gotta take you know I
mean like take the heat I get the
message across but there is hope for the
Bryce's out there there is there's a
human in there because again you know a
lot of these these instances of rape and
sexual assault are from someone that you
already know that's an oppressor chol
the majority of them happen from someone
that you were your fan
they already knows you know it's it's
usually not a stranger so a lot of these
cases are just you know people who have
lost their way or haven't been educated
on what consent is or haven't been
taught how to respect women or how to
respect human beings in general so
that's something that can change as we
start to have more of these
conversations and influencing people so
there is hope out there just don't know
if there is for Bryce I don't yeah
that's very Selena Gomez is of course
one of the executive producers how
involved was she this season she was
pretty involved there the table reads
and everything they like Skype in
because they have busy and her mother
have super busy schedules but but
they'll Skype in and watch the table
reads and and then I'm sure they give
their sort of creative notes to the
network heads and whatnot I'm not
involved in that side of it so I don't
know but but they always pop in they
come up we'll have dinners and get
together and talk about you know
storyline and cast yeah and that stuff
was awesome what did you make of
Netflix's decision to cancel a premiere
I stand by it I feel made sense and
solidarity for what was going on again
with the gun issues in our own show and
the parallel to what happened in Texas I
think it was the right move we didn't
want to go out and totally have this big
fanfare premiere party celebration when
something like that it just happens ya
know heartbreaking across the board you
have so many questions thank you guys
for Wow
okay how have you dealt with Fame on
social media whoo that's a good question
I I don't know I mean I certainly
monitor I think more what I post
yeah head of a perfectionist anyway but
yeah I'm always very consciously aware
of what I post and and how it might be
construed but yeah it's kind of it's
kind of crazy because with season 1 it's
just like you know I think all of us
went from hundreds or potentially
thousands to like millions of rares
almost overnight it's crazy to see like
all the comments and all the lakes you
guys get am I your host once I thank you
for the support it's amazing yeah do you
think that Bryce cares for Chloe Jenna
wants to know in his own way I think I
think there is a lot of manipulation I
think it does look good for him and his
image in terms of what's going on
but I I think I think more Brice once to
love for I think more than he actually
loves her I think he really wants to I
think I think in Bryce's mind he likes
the idea of putting this behind him and
and trying to go a straight and narrow
if that's at all possible he likes the
idea I think of eventually a family or
kids or someone who you know his parents
were never there so he loves the
affection you know when when he gets it
so I think he likes the idea of Chloe or
a Chloe or a close-knit relationship
I don't know necessarily if Chloe is the
one but I think he likes the idea of in
him something that Bryce's dad said that
I love was a woman who loves you is
meant to be respected not crossed and I
was like you better preach dad that was
really good at it but then at the same
note to you also see the Walker side
where and you know what this is
interesting I don't know if it ended up
making it into the final cut but I
remember it being in one of the versions
of the scripts and it was essentially
like she's gonna it was something along
the lines of she's gonna look good for
the jury or it doesn't matter because I
asked do you think my mom like Sharon is
like okay good
do you think mom likes her and and he's
like it's she's she looks good anything
with a glasses too the whole Clark Kent
right there I want to know what's uh
what's like on your acting buckless or
do you have any upcoming projects we
should be aware of like what's next for
you um I'd like to dabble more behind
camera as well I love acting so I'm
working on a feature now with my
girlfriend she's director so so we're
working on getting that kind of off the
ground which will be fun auditioning a
lot I love I'd love to play a character
that's the complete opposite right next
that's kind of the goal at this moment
what does the girlfriend make of the
show and the character she's very
supportive yeah so she's in the industry
she is she's a director immensely
supportive and has watched both seasons
and their entirety and has found a way
to disconnect me from Brice we have to
you have to
well we film up north and and while we
were filming she'd come up and visit and
there'd be
I was alright politely be like hey so
this week's gonna be really intense if
you wouldn't mind and she's like I get
it I'm out and she'd come back and
that's great that she understands that
very supportive yeah last question on
YouTube
shadow skew 11 says how do you feel
about the ending uh there were a lot of
endings there was a lot that went on an
episode yeah in terms of I guess Bryce's
ending it pisses me off but again I I
kind of knew it was coming because it's
realistic
so I think they made the right call with
that in terms of the shooting I'm glad
nothing happened but who knows if we did
a third season I guess I don't know I
think it was I think it was done well
I'm happy with all of the little you
know plot points that we kind of had all
the some of the tied up ends some of the
loose ends some open up
why don't they you know exactly there
were a lot of fun moments to like I the
the the dance scene I think had a lot of
good moments and I just like with the
song coming on and the whole group
coming you know it's beautiful that's
really well done this is why we need a
season three years so there's a lot of
love questions left unanswered you know
yeah is there a place for Hannah in
season three I feel like so much of the
season was about clay letting Hannah go
right I don't know I don't know yeah
that is a really good question I feel
like he does he's sort of let's go and
there's that beautiful moment where
she's like it's time I have to let you
go and yeah it seems like she does go so
it might seem odd just season three
she's just definitely like oh but what
about when that big mano here just ahead
I don't know I'm not sure maybe I mean I
love Katherine they can find a way to
make it work I think it would be amazing
sure but I have no idea no idea
well congrats on an amazing season if
you guys haven't matched it all yet do
it they're all there for you
sure you use those resources that are
amazing yeah thank you guys make sure
you that you subscribe like follow along
with Justin on social media and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you